welcome to the future of Life Institute
podcast my name is Gus doer and I'm here
with Mark brle Mark welcome to the
podcast thanks guys Mark is my colleague
at at fli and he's the director of
policy uh maybe you can tell us about
this AI safety Summit in the UK that
you're attending right now definitely
we're I mean it's usually exciting and I
think quite a big moment for AI
governance U there's been lots of
Articles coming out in the lead up to it
lots of I think attention on social
media uh and we just had day one we're
recording this on the morning of day two
of the summit so I can't give the full
details because um it hasn't fully
happened yet um but I think there's
already some um exciting things to
report there were 28 countries present
and they released a statement yesterday
in which they released a shared
understanding around uh the potential
catastrophic risks of AI um and I think
that's a milestone that we haven't uh
seen before and we saw saw some
announcements sort of on the sidelines
of the summit so we had the UK already
announced their Frontier task force um
but now there's also um a US AI safety
Institute um that the Secretary of
Commerce announced yesterday at the
summit and I think it's it it shows like
a growing movement towards Nations doing
their own AI Safety Research and sort of
taking more ownership of that into the
public sector um so I think that's
that's also a huge development and
fli Tim shrier one of our other
colleagues he put out some
recommendations back in September for
the summit and one key thing we said is
given the pace of the technology and the
development we need to make sure that
the next Summit happens in six months
time uh and I'm super happy that the
Brits uh agreed to that and they got
South Korea to host the next Summit in
six months then um France in a year's
time uh so those are both confirmed and
I saw a rumor this morning that can
might be up in 18 months so I think it's
really exciting to see that um this is
not just a one-off event but it's
becoming uh a trajectory and a process
um that hopefully will lead us to um a
safer world this sounds fantastic this
sounds pretty positive above my
expectations what what about um what
about the role of China at the summit uh
so they were there not there there I
think in the weeks leading up to it and
there was a lot of back and forth um fli
strongly recommended that China would be
involved we feel that AI safety isn't
and and sort of risks of loss of control
risks of misuse are Global risks that um
I think we can find common ground on
with China even though there might be
some elements of AI policy or many
elements of AI policy that we can't that
doesn't mean that you can't um also have
meetings with with the Chinese
government um and in the end um they
were invited uh until I think three days
AG go still only for day one uh but they
now also get to be there for the second
day um which is the day that is in many
ways more important because it has a
smaller number of participants um and uh
it's also where the Prime Minister
himself uh sunak will be chairing and um
yeah I think it's really great that the
Chinese government is involved at this
level and is on a Podium together with
the United States which we saw yesterday
at the summit we see saw both China and
the US um sharing a Podium and I think
had had let's say Beijing hosted this or
had DC hosted this you wouldn't have
seen that Dynamic so I think that is
also sort of an exciting piece and I
think also the thing that really sets
this Summit apart from any other AI
discussion so what what's the
significance of the symbolism there how
much does does something like that mean
sharing a stage together I mean you see
a lot of competition emerging between
governments on who can do the best AI
regulation and who is defined defining
the the the technology you I me you saw
the EU come out very early with its AI
act and then I think some unease in DC
about sort of is this a repeat of data
privacy where the EU developed a law and
sort of US states copied it and sort of
the US was was sort of Left Behind and
didn't have much influence in shaping
that so I think there was I mean I think
that in part helped spur things like the
Insight fora in in in in the US Congress
where Senate Majority Leader Schumer
brought together lots of experts and uh
where Max techar our president
participated and you saw earlier this
week on Monday Biden come out with an
executive order uh regulating uh
artificial intelligence and putting down
some um yeah I think first significant
um rules so that's an added element of
of um government involvement and then
China had already developed um its own
rules earlier in the year
has also put put them out over the
course of this year so having the US and
China both in the room means that in
that competition hopefully you can get a
degree of convergence as well and you
avoid separate processes where China
goes off on one end and tries to
mobilize a group of Nations and the US
goes off on another I think like given
the importance of the issue and the
importance of global coherence and
enforcement we can't really afford
having two or three different processes
that exist side by side so some
organizations at the summit are
interested in what's called responsible
scaling of Frontier models is that the
regulatory approach that that most are
in favor of and and what do you think of
this approach I think the approach
gained a lot of ground in the weeks
before the summit and then sort of did a
bit of a belly flop uh the week before
um where I think there was a lot of push
back uh and I think I mean Twitter was
full of push back and memes uh where
people were suggesting that adding the
adjective responsible in front of
scaling U doesn't suddenly give you AI
safety and I think that that is a an
important message uh one I agree with I
mean if the emphasis here is
unresponsible and if if that is made to
mean something I think it can be quite
good and I think um a company like
anthropic putting out four AI safety
levels saying okay um if someone uh
independently verifies that the models
that we're going to put out um have
significant risk of misuse then we won't
put them out and won't deploy them I
think that that is a helpful commitment
it will help policy makers Define how to
like set rules um so I think it's great
that companies participate in that but
it's also a very narrow approach to AI
governance and um what we've done is
we've put out some analysis um just in
the days leading up to the summit and
that was published um yesterday and you
can find it on futureof life.org
SSP and that get takes you to a
comparison table uh which Compares for
example The entropic Proposal but also
many governance proposals the EU act the
Biden executive order um various other
um proposals put out by industry and you
can see what elements they do have and
but more importantly I think what
elements they don't have um for example
responsible scaling doesn't include a
mandate to register your AI model it
doesn't uh say anything about who's
liable if you cause massive harm with
your system and those are sort of
important elements of policy that we
also need um so that's really critical
as we sort of assess responsible scaling
uh and maybe expand it a little bit and
I think the companies themselves in at
least in my analysis would probably want
that as well I think they realize that
they're in a like they're in a
competitive environment they can like be
committed to safety also at a personal
level at a company level but there's
limits to that because ultimately they
also need to make a profit to stay
afloat that means that to ensure a Level
Playing Field you need some sort of
enforced regulation and some of that
will have to come from policy makers and
not from the companies or their policies
yeah some proponents of responsible
scaling frame this as the pragmatic
Choice the the politically feasible
approach to regulation so even though we
might not get we might wish that we
could get something more comprehensive
we probably can't and so we should go
for for the more pragmatic Choice what
do you what do you think about that I
think the the policy environment is
changing very very rapidly if you told
me in February the month before we put
out our open letter that I would be
sitting here in the UK in November at a
government Summit about AI safety uh and
there would be three more coming in in
18 months like I would have laughed you
out of the room
so I think G given that all of this is
happening and you see this dynamism and
you see policy makers really stepping up
like two or three like going into sort
of an extra gear um I'm not sure if now
is the time for pragmatism I think we
can be we can be ambitious at the moment
we can um go much further than like the
absolute lowest common denominator and I
think we also have an obligation to
encourage policy makers companies
academics to to be ambitious certainly
has been interesting to see King Charles
and President Biden talk about AI safety
which I just hadn't seen coming if even
even a year ago when when we look back
do you think we'll see this Summit as a
turning point for AI safety I know it's
early days I know it's it's perhaps too
early to declare Victory but it sounds
pretty positive especially with the
commitments to host further Summits and
to to get something done here yeah I
think maybe just to pick up on what you
said earlier about of Biden coming out
out to talk about AI safety and and King
Charles talking about AI safety I was at
the a round table organized by the
British Embassy in Washington two weeks
ago where also like the whole British
diplomatic system like was explaining to
American agencies you know what AI
safety is what their Vision was for the
summit and um I haven't seen all the
other embassies of the UK doing this in
the other 27 countries but I'm sure
similar things has have happened and I
think it really shows in a way the power
of a bureaucracy when it does move into
action is that you just have a
multiplier effect that is so much larger
than you can achieve as a sort of small
community of academics or people that
are concerned about this issue in terms
of whether this Summit is a turning
point I'd like to think so I mean it's
it's pretty exciting that we had our fli
conference back in 2015 on AI safety
which was arguably the first uh and now
to see this at a government level I
think is a is a milestone but it also
like despite the sort of pump and
ceremony and the King being there we
shouldn't forget that like that doesn't
create enforcement agencies or hard law
and I think that's still work that needs
to be done and I think it's also left
for the next Summit to Define yeah can
we get to hard International agreements
um the establishment of agencies so I
think we can be pleased um but we should
also shouldn't celebrate uh everything
yet yeah I guess we have seen before and
now I'm thinking about climate change a
lot of strong rhetoric but perhaps not a
lot of U political action following up
on on that rhetoric or at least in my
opinion not enough to what extent are
governments paying attention to to AI at
at the moment where would you rank this
in in the kind of in a ranked list of of
issues it's safe to say that AI
governance showed up on the list of
issues and um it's like where previously
this was being discussed only by civil
servants at a sort of expert level now
it sometimes reached the head of state
with the head of government so that's
that's pretty impressive um then again
there's also other issues that
governments need to worry about and um I
mean the the conflict in Israel Gaza is
a good example of something that's
currently dominating Global headlines
and yeah I I find it hard to provide a
perfect ranking but um it's entered the
top five I think when you when you talk
to policy makers and government
officials are they managing to keep up
with the pace of AI development this
this might be an enormous ask because I
think even people who work on on AI are
have trouble keeping up so yeah how how
informed are policy makers and and how
does this influence uh what's
politically possible I seen a lot of
pleas for people saying like please stop
publishing articles can we please stop
doing Su like I need a break I need to
read so I think that's yeah I think that
feeling of overwhelm is with everyone
working in AI governance can policy
makers keep up I mean they'll they'll
strug struggle to keep up with the pace
of any development I mean they're also
only people and they have a lot of
responsibilities to take care of in a
week but I think it is really impressive
to see people who have been engaging
deeply with AI in various jurisdictions
really get to grips with it um I think a
really good example is dragos taraka
who's the MEP from Romania that's one of
the co-leaders on the AI act together
with Brando benefi from from Italy and
they have been like working on this
proposal ever since it was introduced
back in May 2021 April 2021 into the
parliament by the European commission
and like it's it's obvious how much
their understanding has grown of the
issue how much more sophisticated the
debate has gone how much clearer they
have the clear their perspective has
become of the risks um and I think you
can say something similar about um the
discussions that maybe um the US
Congress was having on AI six months ago
to now where you see okay they've had a
number of briefings and people are
talking about do we need licensing yes
or no and do we need registration do we
need monitoring of computational
clusters and I think that's that's a
whole level of sophistication that
didn't exist half a year ago and so yeah
I think you do see a lot of development
for non- insiders could you give us an
overview of the landscape of AI policy
in in Brussels and in Washington this is
allall order I think
in Brussels I think you have the
traditional left right Axis where like
the left will be more supportive of
government intervention more worried
about the harms the right wants to sort
of ensure that the role of governments
is relatively limited and I think are
more concerned about
Innovation the EU given its history is
also ultimately regulating a market I
mean that's uh what they know to do and
and and what they've done for many
decades and they think less about
Industrial policy putting lots of money
behind the technology or geopolitics
because the EU doesn't have an army so
the perspective is in a way quite narrow
and quite focused on on
limitations and I think a lot of the
debate in in Brussels is around the role
of big players big Tech to what extent
do we do we limit them and the role of
AI in National Security can you have
realtime biometric surveillance under
what conditions for what crimes I think
those are I think two additional sort of
axes the role of big tech and and sort
of the role of AI National Security that
are defining the the policy landscape in
Brussels in DC I think you don't see
that level of detail yet because it's
still quite early days and there isn't a
law a legal
proposal um or a bill introduced yet
that everyone has converged around there
are num there are a lot of bills
floating around but there isn't one game
in town that everyone is trying to
define a position on yet and I think you
see a
development in us I think National
debate around the role of social media
in public life um and whether that's a
good or a bad thing and and I think
potentially a realization on with both
the Republican party and the Democratic
party that they should have intervened
earlier um in social media and there
should have been a role for government
there um and I think people are trying
to draw lessons from that experience for
AI yet I don't think everyone's certain
yet on how they want to go and do that
yeah what explains this difference
between the EU and the us where the EU
seems to be in in front on the
regulation which which is kind of funny
since the US has most of the large AI
corporations yeah what explains this why
why is this how things are I find that
hard to pinpoint that exactly I mean in
a way it might be a little bit random uh
I think there is an element in of of
accident or luck in that the European
Parliament set up this uh thematic
committee on AI a few years ago and I
those discussions I think led to an
early awareness that that legal action
might be necessary and I think it's also
maybe a function of the Electoral cycle
if you compare that between the US and
the EU where the US of course has
midterms every four years elects a new
president whereas the European
Parliament only get gets elected every 5
Years and we're currently at the very
end of that electoral cycle like the
elections are in in Spring uh next year
so no one had to worry too much about
sort of being reelected for a while I
think there was a lot of deep focus on
sort of policy and I mean there is of
course this meme in European politics
that many people will send their
National politicians to Brussels if um
they don't want if they want to get rid
of them um and in a way Brussels is just
still less visible than maybe politics
in Berlin or politics in Paris is to
French or German people and that does
mean that people are maybe able to
respond to these technological
developments in and and sort of have
more time to think and consider and
contemplate them than maybe in some
national political environments it's
surprising to me that the US isn't in
front on regulation and this is this is
kind of you can set aside whether you're
you're Pro uh kind of comprehensive
regul or whether you want you want a
lighter touch regulation it's just that
it would seem obvious to me that the the
country that's in front on on the
technology side would also be in front
on the regulation side I guess that's
that's just not how things are do you
think the US government can figure out
who is responsible for regulating AI who
internally within the government I mean
yeah I mean maybe just to go back to
that surprise I mean I think there is a
mentality uh in Silicon Valley to sort
of Go Fast and break things and I think
that that has yielded lots of companies
Innovation GDP growth for the United
States so I think it's not like
entirely overwhelmingly surprising that
there is no regulation I mean I think
that it's a business model that has
worked well for for the country but we
do see a changing world where I think
it's not so obvious anymore like it has
been for at least in the 90s and the the
early 2000s that the US was the only
dominant rule Setter and I think the US
is now waking up to the fact that I mean
the EU and its data privacy regulation
but uh most certainly also the Chinese
in in in in developing standards in in
Technologies are is presenting rival
options and um that means that there may
be more needs for us regulation and sort
of us leadership if they want to
influence the direction of this
technology than there has been before so
I think I like I think that is now
changing and and that might lead to more
surprise if you will on sort of the yeah
where in the US government this needs to
sit um I mean that's a really tough
question and I think it's become harder
and harder in the US system to introduce
new agencies and set up new authorities
the executive order assigns most of the
enforcement responsibility to nist um
the National Institute for standards and
technology that agency can't enforce
anything um so that is somewhat atic and
I think also ideally something that
either we change or we think about is
there another entity maybe within the
department of energy that does have that
enforcement Authority um and can make
sure that rules that are eventually
passed by Congress U that people also
abide by them and and sort of we we take
the laggers along how much do we know
about what's happening in China and and
India on the policy side I'm not a China
expert or an and I know far less about
Chinese AI policy than I do about the EU
or the us then again I think we we've
seen a willingness with the Chinese
government to regulate and they've
introduced uh a number of guidelines and
rules also about ensuring that any
outputs of AI models are in line with
the values that the Chinese government
wants to see and around the AI Summit
where um China was um or is
participating we also saw statement
released by Chinese and Western
academics where the Chinese delegation
and participants also really backed this
concept of of regulating artificial
intelligence and in a way I think it it
it shows that the outlier at this point
is is the US um and I think the
executive order to some extent remedies
that but yeah the CH China has put hard
law onto the books and so so I mean the
EU is about to do the same yeah maybe we
should actually talk about this
executive order what what's what's the
content of it uh it's early days and
we've done some analysis um but it
requires things like red teaming on on
the part of the companies um and also um
mandates that the companies share that
information and the results of that red
teaming with the US government it talks
about training runs initiated by Foreign
entities and making sure that uh again
the US government is notified of those
large training runs but it also goes
into things like the role of AI in
housing the role of AI in uh employment
uh in education making sure that people
have the right skills uh so it's it's a
really wide ranging um executive order
and what I quite like about it is that
it in a way puts to bed this endless
ethics versus safety debate because it
shows that you can have one executive
order that in a way addresses all of the
whole range of risks and harms from a
um and you don't have to have an
instrument that just worries about one
side of it and I think the AI act in in
in the EU shows something very similar
in that it also tries to deal with both
risks from AI in uh as it comes to
integrating the in critical
infrastructure or in hiring algorithms
and what happens with the most advanced
uh general purpose SL Frontier models so
I think we should talk about some lines
of skepticism about AI policy and one of
the the ones I I hear most often is that
AI policy will just be too slow to
matter so the systems will have moved on
whenever the legislation is is
implemented now I we just talked about
how things are moving pretty fast and
perhaps faster than they have in the
past but are are you hopeful that policy
will will move fast enough in in general
to keep up with the pace of AI so you're
speaking to the head of policy so I'm
going to obviously defend uh the the
role of policy and also I mean I
completely grant that um this is not the
only thing that we need to do and we
also need to work out the the technical
details of how to make these systems
safer or how to build safe Ai and like
that I think doesn't mean that you sort
of drop policy or stop doing it I think
that the accelerating pace of
governments engaging with AI governance
is really promising and I think shows
that much more is possible than people
maybe have would have assumed or would
have thought a year ago so I think
that's one but I grant that policy moves
at a certain Pace especially in
Democratic countries where um things
need to be deliberated everyone gets to
put in their perspective um that's what
usually leads to better policies than um
if a dictator would just lay them down
um but it does mean that you are like
that you are under certain constraints
and you can't maybe move as fast as you
would like does that mean that if you
get super harmful out of control AI
sooner than policy makers are ready for
it that you have a potentially massive
problem yes that that is true does that
mean that you then stop working on it on
on like because there is that
probability however High you think it is
like a world ending event would come
before the policy is in place
well I mean that doesn't seem rational
to me either I think you you do want to
ensure that you you put the policies on
the books you hope that they're in time
and you make sure that you ALS pursue
other um actions yeah one point you've
made is that we are we're racing towards
Advanced AI now and we want to have
policies in place before we hit a point
where we we are unable to act so we
can't we we can't begin thinking about
policy when we when we are say one year
away from from Advanced Ai and this is a
meme that does exist with many people
working on AI safety uh especially when
I joined fli um two two and a half years
ago I was meeting a lot of people that
said said well like this whole policy
thing like let's let's wait for a couple
of years uh let's do lots more research
and then uh let's develop AI systems and
just when they get like terribly
dangerous that's when we call the
government and we put out one academic
article on say archive and we tell
everyone on the internet that this is
where the governments need to step in
and then we have the problem solved and
I think i' I've like I find that deeply
frustrating because that's not how
governments tend to work governments
need a lot of time espe like as we
talked about I mean democratic
governments need time to deliberate but
also to build a bureaucracy or to set up
a department that doesn't happen
overnight um and you need to hire
experts and um build that government
capacity way before you get to the cliff
Edge this is why I think it's super
important to start doing this work and
to make sure you do that way before you
reach uh like a point of no return yeah
maybe this instinct to wait and and do
more research comes from a worry about
the regulation we we then do Implement
being too being kind of rushed and uh
and not polished and and perhaps not
informed this is kind of the opposite
question of what I just asked we worri
that we're rushing towards regulation
now before we have a full overview of of
AI risks I think we need to ask
ourselves what we want AI for and um I
think this doesn't happen enough it's
something that um our executive director
Anthony Aira in in a recent paper also
closing the gate also highlighted you
think see things like Alpha fold where
deep Minds developed a system that can
predict protein folding that's hugely
important to to biology um that doesn't
require the sort of scaling that we've
seen coming out of meta or um open AI or
anthropic and as we put in regulation
that potentially harms scaling um or
potentially makes it more difficult to
build ever bigger black boxes that you
can
commercialize um and delays po potential
benefits that we will discover around
those I mean okay yes that is that is a
potential downside I I grant you that
but as long as we can still define
specific benefits that we want from AI
in narrow Fields such as biology um or
health care or um I don't know
Transportation uh inste driving cars
then we probably can reap most of the
benefits from AI development um in in
ways that aren't going to be affected by
regulatory efforts that Target the most
risky systems so in a many ways I think
you can have your cake and eat it yeah
we can imagine systems that are highly
capable in more narrow domains and
therefore do not pose the same risks of
losing control of of the systems that
that more General systems might do okay
here's another skeptical uh question for
you so you could say open AI Deep Mind
anthropic and and so on these these top
AI uh AI corporations are interested in
regulation because they want to capture
that regulation and then make it
beneficial for themselves and keep out
the competition how much do you worry
about this I worry about this somewhat I
think to some extent it is a legitimate
concern that we need to worry about I do
also compare AI policy to other policy
areas I mean if think of pharmaceuticals
we don't like we've moved beyond the
world where anyone could just develop a
potion um and sell it to someone else
and be like oh this will make your skin
glow or make your hair grow back um and
we've we've put reg Regulation and
Licensing in in place so that if you
like get prescribed some sort of
medication you know that it tends to
work or at least there's some evidence
based around it and that has led to some
concentration right your grandma can't
put out her potion anymore as uh and
claim um that it's
beneficial um in in a medical way so I
mean I think we've accepted in that
domain some costs as Society U and some
limits and some some concentration
because we think the benefits are worth
it and I think we need to strike that
balance in AI as well where yes it is it
is a trade-off sure and people will have
different opinions about that tradeoff
um but I think if we want to protect our
societies we do need some entities that
we can hold responsible
um and this might be where collaboration
is going to be really important can we
build an institution where uh we have
Democratic oversight we have
participation of um researchers from
different countries who get access to
systems or maybe who build systems uh
collectively um so that you still can
report about those systems transparently
you can make sure that um all the
information and power isn't controlled
within private sector entities but you
still maintain some level of oversight
that is much more powerful than just
like a freefor all world if top AI
corporations want to collaborate about
around slowing down or implementing
safety policies could they be prevented
from doing so by antitrust regulation
this is a really good question and we
would need an antitrust lawyer to look
into that but I I I don't feel expert
enough to answer it okay then let's talk
about uh the the EU AI act where you I I
at least perceive you as an expert um
how is this act set up what is it trying
to achieve so when the eui Act was
introduced it was uh introduced to um
identify different AI systems and what
kind of risks they carry so systems that
allow you to build a social scoring
system for your government or your
municipality where for example if you
cross a red light in Copenhagen you
would lose 10 points but if you would
take care of um your elderly relative
gain five um those are prohibited
similarly subliminal manipulation uh is
a prohibited application so those are um
examples of things that that the AI act
prohibits then the AI act also
identifies a number of um AI
applications as high risk so there's a a
list under the AI AC of um areas or
sectors such as for example the incorpor
of AI in critical infrastructure or the
incorporation of AI in hiring decisions
um where you're allowed to use it but if
you do you have to show what data set
went into your system is there did you
take any measures against bias uh what
risks do you see um what mitigation
measures have you taken so there's a
burden on you to show that you've um
taken appropriate safeguards um and it's
not that all AI systems that are used in
those sectors are going are going to be
be regulated under the latest compromise
um it's only those that propose
particularly severe risks in those
sectors that that are in scope um and
then anything else um is is seen as low
risk um and there will be some voluntary
guidance that companies can follow if
they have a lowrisk application but
other than that they are um free to do
whatever they want and they're not
really touched by by the AI act what
would be some some examples of something
that's in scope of the ACT versus
something that's out of scope yeah so
like um a hiring algorithm is is a good
example of something that's that's in
scope a biometric identification systems
uh used by the police um is is is
something that's in scope um where
there's you need to satisfy a number of
criteria to be able to to use that and
there's some that still argue that it
shouldn't be allowed in any case then
examples of things that wouldn't be in
scope is AI using navigation for example
in Google Maps um where um the really
doesn't touch it um at all for example
when it comes to generating content uh
such as images or or Voice or um text
you have to disclose that it is
generated by an AI system but other
other than that you also don't have to
abide by any further requirements beyond
the sort of message that this was
generated by AI um so that is an example
of where where the Act only has a very
light touch approach yeah I imagine such
a such an act is is a it's a product of
compromise it's being stretched by one
faction and and pulled in another
Direction by another faction and you
know what do you what do you think of
the act as it's as it stands now what
are the pros what are the cons in in
your view yeah I mean it is definitely a
sausage that's being produced by by by
many and I mean obviously like knowing
how the sausage gets made is is not
something you often want to know or
should be known I think one thing that
fli asked for from the very beginning
was making sure that more General
systems um such as gp4 those models are
also regulated um and that the burden on
identifying the risks that those systems
POS is really placed on the big players
at the source of the value chain and not
towards the end of it initially because
of the application based approach of the
ACT if you are a small medium Enterprise
or entity let's say Hospital
and you take uh a chat bot um and build
or build a chat bot on top of gp4 um to
do your contact with your patients then
you as a hospital are liable for
anything and everything that the system
um outputs even though you might not
understand what application you have
bought and I think making sure that that
responsibility is allocated in the right
place is something we've yeah we've
spoken up about and I think uh we now
also see that the ACT is updated in that
way but on the sort of pro process of
making the ACT I think it's important
that people realize that the reason it
takes a very long time and the reason
that uh it sometimes gets stretched in
in in different ways is most often
because the major companies from from
the US have a lot of lobbyists and will
try and Pull It in One Direction or
another and delay it um and I think that
yeah uh I guess this is to be expected
but the EU takes a lot of blame for what
is ultimately caused by corporate
lobbying um namely delay or or
complicated law with exemptions um and I
think For Better or For Worse the the
lawmakers involved are trying their best
to have and introduce the first ever AI
law um that is as good as possible but
it is often affected by by this
corporate influence is it a problem in
your opinion that the EU AI act does not
regulate military
applications no one of the other
projects that we're working on is a
treaty on autonomous weapons and the
issue of autonomous
autonomy and weapon systems and you see
a lot of division still within NATO and
within European union members of NATO
and if you would have introduced milit
like guidelines or rules for military
applications in this law I don't think
you would have reached any agreement so
I think it does make sense to exempt it
so that you can focus on what you can
agree on as you navigate military
applications one thing that I think is a
mistake is that if the the law only
regulates AI applications that you put
on the market in Europe so if you're a
European company and you're based in
Slovakia and you export to Uganda say
you can do whatever you want and you
don't have to abide by any element of
the AI act even though your product is
made in Europe and I think that is
problematic because that I can see that
technology getting Incorporated in for
example uh surveillance where yeah it
isn't quite sort of military
applications but I think it does um
contribute to authoritarianism and to
instability potentially in in this world
um where I think the eui ACT could have
done more how is the act enforced I I've
heard some complaints that there isn't
enough third-party enforcement of of uh
of compliance with the ACT yeah it's so
there is a a regime for third party uh
auditing that the ACT
produces uh but it's a very limited
number of applications that are covered
by that making sure that that third
party auditing is introduced for the
general purpose AI systems the GPT Force
plus of this world um and that that
isn't left to some
independent evaluators of limited status
uh without any sort of rules or
guidelines or even to the companies
themselves um and I think within the AI
safety Community we often hear this word
evals which I if I can put this out on
this podcast that I really hope that
word dies very quickly I don't
understand why you would abbreviate the
word evaluations but uh it also is a is
a rather meaningless term because I mean
I can evaluate your height and say that
you're an x height but then have I
evaluated the right thing and I think an
audit and because we can we see
comparisons from the financial sector
for example is a much better defined
concept um and at Le to me means that
it's an independent third party and you
have a set of metrics that independent
third party evaluates you against and
that you as a company can't influence
and I think we really need to move to
that um in AI governance and away from
from this thing called eval you would
still need some research on developing
these metrics and I guess there the the
you could take inspiration from the
research that's being done on
evaluations which are kind of ideas
about finding out in which cases are
systems dangerous and how they might be
dangerous so it might not be fully
incompatible all these two approaches oh
no definitely I mean the work itself is
super important and I think we
definitely need lots more of that uh but
I think we need to also understand the
the power dynamics that are at play here
it's not just about developing the
concept and the metrics and the
benchmarks it's also making sure that
people actually meet them abide by them
and get punished if they don't and
that's arguably not something you can
have an in like an evaluator a random
sort of evaluator without any status
that
how much does the EU AI act matter given
that most of the Cutting Edge AI
activity is in the US I think policy
makers look at other policy makers when
they uh start to develop any legislation
and I think the eui ACT matters because
it actually gives an example and a
blueprint of how you could do this thing
and yeah if you're a a low-level um
civil servant and you're given the task
of writing your legislation in the US
say U you're going to have a a close
look at what other people have written
and you're going to end up with the euu
act because it in many ways is the only
game in town there is also only so many
ways you can like Define a rule about
transparency you're going to R run out
of ways to write this down in law so um
yes some of the elements of policy I
think there will be diverence there will
be different options but I think yeah
for some basic concepts I think the EU
will probably arrived at some compromise
or solution that many will be tempted to
adopt and you see for example in the
Brazilian Senate a law has been
introduced that copies many many
elements of the EU AI act and if
companies want to sell their products
outside of the US and you see more and
more jurisdictions adopting elements or
all of the eui ACT I think the incentive
for them to abide by by it or by parts
of it becomes greater and that becomes
even more so if individual US states
adopt elements of the act as we saw with
data privacy laws where California
copied the framework of the EU so most
of the AI development or leading AI
development currently happens in the US
but that doesn't mean that that the EU
bill doesn't have impact how do you
think it it plays in US politics if you
if you are accused so to speak of of
Taken inspiration from the Europeans you
probably don't want to say that youve
taken inspiration from the Europeans and
I mean you see that also around this
Summit now right like see um in the same
week of both the UK government saying
they are leading the field on AI
regulation look at our Summit and you
see Biden saying we're leading the field
in AI because look at our executive
order so I think that's part of the game
um and it should also be possible I
think to to define a national response
within certain
limits um where where you work towards
convergence and the EU and the United
States together have a a tradeing
Technology Council where they meet Twi
twice a year and discuss AI um and
they've just published a draft list of
terminology in Ai and definitions in Ai
and that I think shows that um yeah
there are just a lot of Concepts and and
and things that that will be shared um
across the world and across multiple
jurisdictions and um
in when we develop benchmarks and
standardization a lot of that will be
held in common even though um yeah there
might still be a national AI policy or a
bill that diverges in in part if we look
beyond the EU AI act and just add
regulation in general why do you worry
more about underregulation than
overregulation I think it's very hard to
once you have a bill on the books
covering a certain area to say that oops
we've missed something really big uh
we're going to have to redo this guys um
and introduce a new AI bill which then
means you are left without the sort of
oomph and and and big moment and
celebration of the fact that that this
is the first AI law know this is this
was the second re revised Edition but it
still needs lots of time it doesn't get
you any press coverage because everyone
like feels it's already been done um
like that's super super hard whereas I
think H having sort of
made sure that we are um safe and sort
of some of the harms that that we fear
don't
materialize that slowing down AI
development and it meaning that some of
the potential benefits are only able to
sort of materialize later uh once we
decide that okay that was really stupid
and it took us a couple of decades but
we had to roll that back to make this
possible to me seems like a much better
approach yes we will lose out on some
benefits but we don't yeah we also sort
of didn't have to worry about some of
the worst harms that that we're
currently discussing I think I think the
worry here from the um let's call it um
anti-regulation side is that these
regulations will stay in place long
after they've served their they've
they've stopped being useful um and
regulations are are difficult to get rid
of and so this idea of rolling it back
once we we we feel like we've
overstepped it might be more difficult
than than we imagine true but I think we
also need to really take a Frank look at
what the up and downside risks and
benefits are here if if we are concerned
about a substantial risk of Extinction
then um I think we we should be willing
to um tolerate some delay um at least
that would be my take okay let's talk
more about us legislation so we we
talked about the executive order there's
also a Schumer Bill what's what's the
content of the Schumer Bill how kind of
fleshed out is this my impression when
doing the research is that I couldn't
find that much us kind of Regulation
that was fleshed out what what do we
know about the Schumer Bill we know very
little about the Schumer bill um because
it doesn't exist yet um there is the set
of insight fora that are being organized
where um Senate Majority Leader Schumer
brings together various experts to talk
about um AI policy and sort of uh
elements of it to try and inform his
bill and you see other senators and
other members of congress come out with
proposals so tedl came out in in in the
House of Representatives with a proposal
for an agency uh we saw Senator Hy and
blumthal come out with a proposal where
they talked about the need for a license
for certain types of models um
registration obligations so I think
those draft proposals uh will likely
influence uh what ends up in the final
bill but it's not there yet so uh I
think we're going to have to wait and
see a little bit what about the AI Bill
of Rights that was introduced I think
some time ago now what's the status on
that this exists and uh so this is a
piece of uh policy that the US federal
government has imposed on itself in a
way it's as asking the US federal
agencies to um look at that Bill of
Rights and and and its guidance as they
Define and and introduce algorithms for
example and I'm from the Netherlands
where um the political debate has been
dominated by something that's now become
known as a Dutch child benefit Scandal
uh where um Your Child Benefits uh if
you if you have a child um and have a
lower income were defined um by an
algorithm an algorithm that still hasn't
been made public um but we do know that
things like someone's second nationality
fed into that algorithm and um whether
or not the algorithm actually found at
fault um was often deeply biased or even
um um I mean there were a huge number of
Errors where people really had there was
absolutely no grounds for including them
on the ultimate fraud list that the
algorithm generated um but it did mean
that some people once they did end up on
that fraud list generated by the
algorithm were forced to pay back all of
their tax rebates or benefits over um
nine eight 10 years a 10 year period at
once um with interest uh it forced some
people to immigrate and leave the
country Child Protection Services
sometimes took children away because
families were unable to provide for for
their children after these measures have
been taken uh some people committed
suicide because of uh ending up in that
situation and I think the AI Bill of
Rights seems to me like a great proposal
to try and at least mitigate those kind
of harms that um are
yeah the government can or risks
bringing over itself or sort of imposing
on its people by uh rushing to introduce
yeah digitalization in areas where that
hasn't been thought through or not all
considerations have been properly
thought about um I mean there's other
examples from other countries you have
the postmaster scandal in the UK where U
people running post offices were accused
of committing fraud when they hadn't um
there's the robo de scandal in Australia
so these are all cases that I think the
US AI Bill of Rights is trying to
prevent happening in the US and the US
government of course is a massive
government and I think in many ways
that's also a blessing because it's
slower to adopt digital technology than
maybe smaller Nations such as the
Netherlands or um Australia or Estonia
uh have done it means it hasn't maybe
seen some of the worst harms yet then
again I mean the Bill of Rights also has
huge limitations it it only applies to
the federal government and that's not
where a lot of the risk of AI
development is coming from so it's great
that we have that Bill of Rights it's
great that we have the executive order
but we also need actual enforcable law
and that's uh where we need to look to
Congress for yeah do do you think the
the AI Bill of Rights might serve as a
as a point of agreement between the two
sides of the debate in that perhaps if
even if you're you're against Reg ation
of private entities you might be
interested in limiting the the powers of
of the government and so there might be
some some some agreement there yeah I
think that the Bill of Rights can feed
into potential legislation and be a good
starting point I definitely don't think
it would be sufficient just to put that
on the books as hard law one thing I
worry about is that we will ask the US
government and we will ask the EU to
regulate
these fast moving Technologies including
AI at a time in which they are becoming
less and less functional a lot hinges on
what happens in the next uh us election
and I imagine that this election could
have a pretty large impact on which
direction uh US policy takes on on the a
AI side do you share this wor what do
you think is is there anything we can do
about it what stance should we take
towards this should we just keep our
heads down and keep working on what's in
front of us or AI policy so far is
remarkably bipartisan and I think there
is a bigger cultural shift around sort
of the role of big Tech in in us life
and how people are re-evaluating and
assessing that that I think is shared on
both the Republican and the Democratic
side and I think that gives me some
confidence that even like the like the
even if political polarization continues
on the trajectory that we see now we're
able to get to some agreement on core AI
governance
decisions but it is definitely a worry
that um Democratic states struggle to um
pass measures that are necessary and
that their people want I mean we there's
been a lot of polling that came out
around AI governance and risks where you
see overwhelming support from the public
to tackle this issue and to have
government step in so um I think there
there is that Democratic base so I think
it yeah we we really do need Congress to
to act upon that but it is a risk one
impression I've gotten from people
working on the technical side of AI
safety is a certain skepticism about
about policy work but also my impression
is that this skepticism has kind of
dissipated lately where people on the on
the technical side of AI safety safety
have become more interested in policy
work perhaps because the field is moving
so so so quickly and many complicated
technical schemes to make AI safe might
not be be done in time um do you share
that impression I do yes I think there
there is a a re-evaluation I think of AI
policy and how quickly there can be CH
change can happen and and what can be
done there I mean maybe I'm going to try
and defend the other side a little bit
in that I think we also do need Moon
shots in AI technical AI safety where I
think there there is a role for
government here to say this is what we
need like these are the features that
we're looking for in in AI development
um that doesn't exist at the moment go
and find out how to do that so that you
take away I think some of the uh talent
and focus from the current Paradigm
which is just scale scale scale towards
things like you know the concept that
Stuart Russell has talked about in terms
of making sure that AI systems always
apply a degree of pro ability towards um
what they know about the world around
them and about what humans want there
might be many other approaches that we
haven't thought of or haven't developed
that could be developed but I think to
some extent you would then need to make
sure that that thinking happens outside
of um the labs that are all sort of
stuck in in this one Paradigm there's
there's obviously a collaboration here
between the technical side and the
policy side where the policy side is
interested in implementing some
solutions that the technical side comes
up with and so on say you're you're
interested in working on AI safety in
general perhaps your your early career
where should you go where where should
you start uh would you go to the
government would you go to Academia
would you go work at one of the AI
companies my recommendation is go to
government um because governments have
woken up this year 2023 to the few of AI
governance and they will be hiring lots
of lots of people and they need to build
that expertise
and they will probably need external
people to come in to help them build
that whereas I think the government the
companies already have ai safety team so
in a way like your added value is going
to be I guess more limited um and I mean
I think that you could say that uh the
same for Academia for governments like I
think it's it's also really important
that that field grows um and that more
and more people take think about these
challenges um and I sort of put the AI
safety into institutes that were
announced this week in the one in the US
and sort of the the expanded one in the
UK as also really good examples of
places where you can work that are sort
of academic government crossover places
I feel that where it it made a lot of
sense to work on AI safety within
companies as they were developing these
very these systems and they were just
like a lot of the underlying
Technologies the the neural Nets were
just developed and released and
discussed I do think that since February
March this year when you saw the
financial times do analysis about how
many billions of dollars are now being
poured into the AI um industry the
profit motive will have overtaken I
think uh the dynamic in many of those
companies perhaps not all but in many
and I think that means that you do need
to think carefully about whether your
role in a company is is the most
effective way to work on on safety of
these systems we can compare this to Big
oil or big tobacco
where people that work for Exxon or
shell might will be really concerned
about climate change on an individual
level but that doesn't mean that they
can change the way that those companies
operate at the end of the day um and I
don't think we can expect AI companies
to be toly different Beasts where
somehow employees in that industry will
be so much more powerful than employees
in other industries that have a clear
profit motive so with that in mind I
think my recommendation would be to to
join the government or to research as an
academic let's talk about kind of which
risks we see from Ai and whether we have
the the tools the kind of regulatory
tools necessary to address these risks
so if we start with something like
um individualized persuasion where you
can you can Target a person and you can
say Okay the reason why you should and
and this person might be part of a very
small group The the reason why you
should vote for for this candidate is
such and such and this has been
infinitely kind of ab tested to be
perfectly tailored to this particular
person do we have the tools necessary to
to regulate something like that we I
mean I think the the EU act attempted by
prohibiting
uh subliminal manipulation I think
nobody really knows what the word
subliminal means and where um this
begins and ends so I think that's a real
challenge I think to some extent any law
is going to have vague Concepts there
are prohibitions that you can probably
lay down that will address some of this
it will you will often want to do this
at scale I would think to have um if you
have a political motive in a democracy
you need to convince a lot of people if
you have a profit motive you want to
sell a lot of product so uh your your
manipulation needs to affect a lot of
people which makes it potentially easier
to detect um or enforce hopefully not
everyone is trying to manipulate other
people so that the number of potential
uh actors that you need to survey might
be relatively limited um which makes me
cautiously optimistic that this might be
possible it's funny that you should
mention uncertainty about the meaning of
certain words in legislation one
frustration I've had in in trying to
read some of this proposed legislation
is just how much hinges on uh
definitions of reasonable and
proportional and necessary in a
democratic uh state or country and so on
is this just is this just this is just
how law functions or could we could we
be more precise in our in our
legislation or would that have some
downsides yeah no I think we really
don't want to be more precise we need
like my pitch here is for constructive
ambiguity especially with the technology
that's so in flux like we need to lay
down what what we want and what we are
worried about and yes we want to give
companies some certainty so I mean there
is a balance to be struck but we also
need to make sure that uh It Isn't So
specific that if a new type of risk
emerges or or something we hadn't
anticipated that we really have to go
all the way back to the drawing board um
and a lot of
legislation that like lays down in Norm
that people will try to respect uh like
we don't rely on courts and judges and
and and finds for most um rule abiding
behavior and I think that is really
critical in that once these concepts are
laid down and people start interpreting
them um most people will make the right
call and will behave in the way that the
lawmakers have intended them to behave
um and it's going to be a very small
minority that will face enforcement
action
um and that means that the law will
bring about the intended effect do you
think we have the regulatory tools
necessary to prevent something like AI
enabled biot terrorism where you use uh
perhaps a Next Generation language model
to tell you how to synthesize something
uh that's that could be very very
dangerous to to all humans with the
current generations of systems where the
jury is still out to what extent they
they amplify these risks um and I think
a lot of research is currently being
done I saw a new report from Rand come
out this week as well where I think they
compare Googling this information versus
using uh a large language model how much
closer or easier does it then become for
a non-sp specialist to develop a weapon
like
this the executive order also um
mandates more oversight of DNA synthesis
um companies and I think that's really
that seems like an obvious policy
measure to take that um you really want
to um develop that is the first time
I've seen any regulator anywhere try to
attempt this so we're not there yet in
any shape or form and um we know both
like we want to make sure that I think
governments improve their their
understanding of their National
landscape like where does where could
buyer risk emerge from in their country
where uh where the companies that could
potentially build this I think to some
extent this links to the open source
question where if you've put guardrails
on your model to prevent this
information from or instructions from
being shared
with just anyone based on any prompt um
and you can put out a model um in such a
way that those guard rails can be easily
remove through fine tuning then yeah
that obviously amplifies the risks and
that that that sort of presents a whole
new range of questions yeah I think the
worry is that some Future model will
will contain some tcid knowledge from
its from its training that's not
available when when you search on Google
it might be able to fill in the gaps uh
in in its guidance of how to synthesize
something dangerous where do you think
we might regulate this so we we could
regulate this by regulating the model
itself that's that's pretty um kind of
heavy-handed perhaps we could regulate
it by regulating the these companies
that uh synthesize DNA or we could
perhaps try to monitor uh Wastewater for
uh what what might become pandemics uh
do you have any thoughts about what what
might be the best best approach for for
this I don't have I think clear thoughts
on where like out of these three options
for example where we would want to put
the heaviest Focus um and yeah I think
things like the r study like are really
critical at this moment to try and
really nail down where we think like how
thises what is the chain of events and
how can we how can we best address this
what about something like Rogue Ai and
here I'm thinking about AI that becomes
more like an agent and less like a tool
perhaps develops motives that we are
that we didn't intend to encode into it
perhaps it begins seeking power in ways
that we uh would like it not to how how
can we how can we regulate this how can
we uh what kind of regulatory tools do
we have available for this yeah so here
you see the um I think there's been a
lot of discussion also within the
partnership uh for AI um on like can you
restrict autonomy um and can you
restrict for example um linking some of
these models to external applications um
or if you do that do that in a phased
way after you release the model um don't
allow sort of any random entity to build
something and integrate it with your
system but um like do a risk analysis
and assessment before you you introduce
that I think there are ways to to limit
this and and to mandate that as well to
try and try and address um yeah these
emerging risks from from increased
autonomy what do you think about open
source um how can we regulate this
because I I i' as I see it there's a
specific challenge here where open
source is decentral Iz it might be
models up uploaded to to decentralized
networks by autonomous people there's no
you can't go knock on the door of uh of
some company that produced the model
necessarily how do you regul regulate
open source AI I find that possibly the
toughest question in AI governance at
the moment how we deal with open source
maybe just taking one step back I think
we need to identify what drives various
people in the debate around open source
I think some people are really concerned
about regulating open source because
they're worried that it will limit
Innovation to us private sector
companies and potentially Chinese
companies but it will cut off the rest
of the world from participating so that
I think that's one group of people and
then you have a different group of
people who are worried about um
surveillance States and sort of um how
much control the the the private sector
would have if if you wouldn't open
source um these systems
and on the other side of the debate you
have people that are really worried
about let's say North Korea obtaining a
system and using it to attack critical
infrastructure or people using a model
to spread death information and sort of
ensure that there's a breakdown of Truth
and having any random um terrorist group
obtain a system um to potentially U
build a bioweapon so I think yeah I
think we need to separate out those
motivations because I think there's a
lot you can do in policy um once you
understand um how you can maybe meet
some of the objectives that some of the
groups in this debate have I would
really recommend everyone who hasn't
done so to read the paper by Meredith
Whitaker the president of signal that
came out a few weeks ago where she
analyzes for example how the push by by
meta for open source is probably
commercially driven and is an attempt to
capture the could be an attempt to
capture the open source ecosystem um in
a sense that you could get lots and lots
of developers to contribute their
knowledge for free and then try and
build a uh proprietary product on top of
that once that Community has offered
things that are almost ready to be built
into a product I think she highlights
there as well is sort of how um the term
open source uh because of its
connotations in software where it's just
one guy writing an open source program
and and everyone feels like really like
all this sympathy towards this one sort
of person Fighting fight um big Tech
uh that positive connotation is used in
in open source AI where uh the situation
is very different because you need a lot
of compute and you need to spend quite a
lot of money to train any system to
evade regulation um where open source
and I think she calls it open source
washing um is is used as as a way to
fight back against the AI act for
example and say no no no we need a world
that's free and open therefore we
shouldn't possibly touch open source as
that argument tends to be driven by um
yeah the likes of meta that sort of have
a commercial or business plan underlying
it rather than um being motivated
entirely by principle then on sort of
the actual policy question of what what
like what we do about it I think we need
to be very specific about the kind of
models that we're worried about I do
think we need to impose restrictions
here in that um we don't allow people to
open like we' been through this in a
many ways with nuclear technology where
um a lot of information around how to
build a nuclear bomb isn't something
that you're free to share if you're a
nuclear physicist in the United States
um for good reason and I think some
recognition that there is yeah that
there are models out there that that
shouldn't proliferate I think at least
from F's perspective is really really
important but I think once you strip
down the debate to its essential
components and understand who's driving
what I think there's also a lot of um
common ground that can be found between
various players in the sense that many
models that are that people are worried
about being restricted probably wouldn't
face any restrictions I think we most
people in this debate can probably agree
that the major players shouldn't be able
to offload the risks that they pose to
society um just by putting something out
as open source um so I think there is
maybe more common ground that can be
found here than than we see at the
moment what about the worry about
centralization I mean we could imagine a
possible future where there one or two a
duopoly perhaps of models that you can
access and perhaps there's a there's a
partnership between the government and
and the companies running these models
and you this is this all begins looking
very uh autocratic perhaps what can we
do to prevent that I think that's where
we need multilateral Corporation um I
think people have talked about aern for
AI I think bu bringing together
various researchers um and governments
working on on this problem and ensuring
that there is sufficient transparency
around that and governmental oversight
um and participation I think is is
really key in trying to tackle this
issue um but there is definitely a
tension right
between trying to liit harms from ever
more powerful systems and like openness
and giving everyone an opportunity to
use those systems I mean um to some
extent you can't exactly have it both
ways um so if you are going to limit the
the number of models or or sort of how
powerful they are then I think doing
that in a controlled environment um that
is as transparent and Democratic as
possible is I think what I hope um
future Summits for example the one in
South Korea or the one in France uh will
be exploring what are your favorite
regulatory tools where a regulatory tool
might be something like saying that a
company needs to um do to do red teaming
and then give data about that red
teaming to the government I think my
favorite uh is risk identification we
saw for example with Facebook and their
social media Newsfeed algorithm that
they knew that this caused um mental
health issues with young women and girls
but that risk and that effect was never
disclosed to the public and I think by
mandating risk identification um you at
least have a basis that you can start to
have a discussion about and you can have
policy makers but also just a general
public and journalists ask questions and
discuss and in many ways the terms and
conditions that of the major players
highlight a number of risks already and
it basically says you can't use our
system for political campaigns or you
can't use our system for
XYZ um and I think that's a good start
um so it's I think in my mind it shows
that this regulatory tool is a is a
possible regulatory tool you can take
that inspiration from the terms and
conditions that exist but you want I
think that list to be as comprehensive
as possible and I think here there's a
real tension between what is in societal
interest and in all of our Collective
interest and what's in the company's
interest right because if I was a lawyer
representing any of the companies I
would say the last thing we want is a
list of risks online because that means
that we had evidence of that risk
materializing and we could be held
liable for it yeah I see the resistance
but I think that is something we we
really do need um and I think it's it's
in my mind is the most important thing
companies doing a Frank risk assessment
and sharing that with all of us and then
the enforcement mechanism is liability
so if they are aware of some risk and
they've published that they're aware of
this risk and then they they still push
ahead then they can be legally ly able
with fines or what what other
consequences might there be well I think
we don't maybe even have to go there
because I think if you've like shouted
about the risks that you see and you've
been forced to tell everyone about them
you're going to do a pretty good job
mitigating them right because you still
want to sell your products and you still
want to have people trust your products
so um and you also just want to avoid a
PR disaster so I think you're going to
want to uh really tell your safety team
to work twice as hard now you've put
that on the internet yes I think
ultimately yeah you also want liability
but my hope is that H having forc to
disclose this and having forc much more
detailed than maybe um the current
safety plans that the companies provide
yeah you motivate these companies to
change course how much do you think
companies are motivated by avoiding PR
disasters versus avoiding say fines I
mean give it how much money is is sort
of earned in this industry and sort of
um at least how how much investment is
being attracted I would think companies
are going to be largely motivated by um
PR risks and reputations the eui ACT
interestingly provides for fines that
are four to six% of annual turnover um
so that means that yeah that the fine
sort of is substantially larger if
you're a substantially larger company um
and means that the a lot of the rules
have teeth and yeah so I think I guess
my answer is like it depends on how you
structure the fines I think reputations
do play a large role in in company
Behavior what do you think of buck
bounties so setting aside a bag of money
and giving that bag of money to to the
person who identifies a vulnerability in
the system I think that's great
that's it seems like something that's
that's pretty easy for the companies to
accept also and perhaps that's why that
some of them have done so so perhaps
that's also a point of of agreement
between many sides in the in the debate
what do you think about governments
subsidizing AI safety work specifically
AI technical AI safety work I think that
is also really important I think we do
need to think very carefully about where
we want AI development to happen and how
and I see a much greater role for the
public for democracies for public debate
to Define like what we want out of AI
development and also
I mean that should then dictate what you
subsidize and maybe that doesn't mean
that you actually subsidize people but
you also bring that into an AI safety
Institute for example that is part of
the government so you may want to go a
lot further than than just providing a
subsidy as well as um multilaterally or
nationally defining certain challenges
that you set to the AI industry or to
researchers for which you potentially
offer a reward if met or or or a
monetary incentive um yeah I could see
those kind of structures um Beyond just
sort of expanding the number of
academics which I think would also be
good uh to make sure that this is an
issue that doesn't just happen at a few
a limited number of Faculty but truly
becomes a Global Research problem
there's also the problem of
distinguishing between Safety Research
and capabilities research where
something like uh reinforcement learning
from Human feedback which is what
basically allowed chat gbt to to work as
well as it as it as it because that was
uh that originated as a Safety project
but it became something that in my
opinion Advanced capabilities so we
would have to be careful about what it
is that we subsidize how we how we test
how we judge whether this is uh pushing
safety forward more than than pushing
capabilities forward and that's that's a
difficult that's a difficult call yeah
so there was an event organized the
night before the summit with Stuart
Russell where he really highlighted that
there's a difference between making AI
safe and making safe AI I think that is
a really essential Truth at least in my
mind that we haven't done enough with
like it is one thing to have companies
just build whatever AI product they want
to and then be like oh we we forgot
about the safety department but thank
God they the third floor let's call them
and ask if they can do some
reinforcement learning by human feedback
or some other measure that they can put
on top to make it safe and starting and
I mean Spirit claim here was this is
never going to work and I I think I to
agree with him whereas the alternative
is making sure that you define from the
outset okay we need something that's
actually safe and it needs to meet these
specifications um and this is therefore
what we're going to build and I think
that's where you need a sort of
nonprofit perspective or government
public sector um to step in um because
incentives might just be different in a
private sector to um that make it harder
not impossible but harder to take that
approach what do you think of compute
governance as a framework where compute
governance might mean something like
putting a cap on the largest training
runs you you can do uh for advanced AI
We compare these various policies to say
okay we need to compute uh computational
Power caps um and and also different
requirements if you exceed certain
levels U including sort of a hard cap
for the highest tier I think this is a
really important part of the
conversation that we and we definitely
needs both monitoring I think at the
moment governments don't even know who
has a lot of computational power in
their country so I think that that's a
really important First Step uh we also
need to make sure that we think about
and discuss with Hardware manufacturers
like how do you build chips and how can
we potentially ensure that chips can be
like the most advanced AI chips can be
turned off um and and how do we we are
there Hardware options that mean that um
you don't know what the system is doing
and you don't sort of interfere in in
sort of uh people's privacy but you are
able to um shut off U particularly large
clusters of the most advanced um
technology I mean the question looming
over this is is it going to be enough or
is it going to be durable probably not
and also is it going to be longlasting
when Computing Hardware becomes better
and better at some point you'll be able
to train
a model that has the same capabilities
as GPT 4 on a gaming uh gaming PC I feel
that on the one hand you see um I'm
taking another Dutch example because
asml is is there as the producer of the
the the chip manufacturing um machines
they were always sort of a commercial
company selling to China selling to the
US selling to anyone who would pay for
their product and suddenly I think they
found themselves in the middle of a a
geopolitical debate um there has been an
agreement reached between Biden the
Japanese and um the Dutch government um
because that's where most of the
advanced Tech in the supply chain comes
from and like suddenly their product
became this hugely political thing that
um I think they needed to Define policy
around and sort of where there are
limits so I think it does show that even
computes can enter a very different
Paradigm um and that uh it's not a given
per se that um the way that the hardware
gets developed will continue in the way
we do it today and and we may want to
reconsider that and I think we need to
buy ourselves a little bit of time I
think we regardless of what risk you see
from AI development there are s like I
think we can all agree that there are
many and they U deserve a societal
response that we are not ready for yet
and I think that the fact that we are
just at the beginning of developing a
lot of legislation of educating policy
makers means we just need to make sure
that we have that time to put that in
place um so if compute governance could
help us by that time until we figured
out something that's more sensible then
I think it's worth pursuing um even
though it's not going to be durable one
reason it might be possible is because
the supply chain of advanced chips is so
uh concentrated in specific companies
like tsmc in Taiwan asml in the
Netherlands Nvidia um and and so there
aren't many places that you you would
have to intervene in order to control um
in specific ways the most advanced chips
I think we should talk a bit about the
ethics of technological transformation
so how do you how do you think about the
fact that we might be rushing towards
Advanced AI
without the agreement or without the
consent of much of the world's
population so you have the leaders of
the top AI companies making predictions
about Advanced AI maybe this decade
perhaps NE next decade and even though
this is becoming a more prominent issue
I'm I'm sure that the that my
grandmother hasn't uh developed a
position on on this and so is it
ethically okay to to develop a a a a
technology that
transformational I find this a tough
question I mean is there an individual
right not to be have your life
transformed by a technology I mean I
think that's that's difficult I mean if
if you know we were living a long long
time ago and someone came around with
the wheel we have been consulted you
know that I mean it does really make
your life very different and you know
you have to find a donkey and
everything that
I'm not sure if I can see like this
ethical Baseline that like you should we
should always have a global poll on any
technological breakr but I think it's
different when there is a risk of
significant harm to you right and I
think that is what we're talking about
in this case where we have many of the
leading AI experts put out probabilities
that that this could even lead to
Extinction that puts us in a different
ball game and I think that is where yes
there is an ethical respons
responsibility on the part of the people
developing this to make sure that um
they only do so once they get the
go-ahead from other people and I think
that's not what we're currently seeing
uh and I think people have a right to be
upset about this I mean I was uh walking
past the pause AI protest at Bletchley
Park where the ukai safety Summit was
held um and you I mean yeah there is
justifiable I think anger and emotion
um when it comes to yeah the lack of
consultation in some of this development
so um yeah I don't think you have a pure
right to be consulted on technological
development but yeah if it if it leads
to significant harm I think there's a
bigger case to be made true and I think
that's the point I wanted to get to that
this this might be different than
introducing a new car or a new
smartphone where it would seem pretty
ridiculous that you would have to
consult everyone in the world before you
actually with the these Technologies
actually did change people's lives but
yeah such a right couldn't couldn't kind
of plausibly exist but when we're
talking about a substantial risk perhaps
of Extinction then then the the game
changes how do we then uh involve people
democratically in in these issues I
think the the ukai safety Summit is a
really massive step forward and uh
Carlos on another fli colleague uh has
sort of met with a number of um uh
governments participating here um that I
think hadn't really thought about AI
safety much before and I think that is a
really really important step similarly
the the UN Secretary General has just
announced a high level advisory body on
AI and our board member and co-founder
Yan talin is is on that I think that's
also a place where you see a lot like
there's it's a there's a broad
representation people from all around
the world a very different backgrounds
um that are trying to Grapple with risks
from AI so I think that's I think the
beginning of setting up structures that
are more Global and and and allow for
more participation but we're a long way
away from that and I mean you we see it
in many other debates I mean nuclear
weapons is is a really good example in
my mind where there are like lots of
people that have don't like live in a
country that has nuclear weapons
but if the great powers do decide to
attack one another they are going to
suffer in in in a nuclear winter and
they have no say over that and were
never consulted um so it's always going
to be I think to some extent limited the
extent to which we can properly consult
everyone based on past examples and I
think still need to do better and I'm
hoping some of these structures the UK
trajectory um the UN secretary General's
initiative
are going to like learn from past
examples but yeah I'm skeptical that
we'll reach Perfection what's the right
model for Global governance of AI what
other organization could we take
inspiration from you thinking of
something like the European Organization
for nuclear research CERN or maybe the
International Space Station or some some
large collaborative Global human project
yeah I think we need multiple Fe
features and maybe not in the same place
um I think I think a CERN is definitely
something we need I mean I think we need
to Ure that more of the development
happens in a way that there is oversight
over it and governments participate in
it rather than just in the private
sector and I see um a c like
collaboration that doesn't maybe have to
be in the same physical location because
you don't need like particle accelerator
exactly um and that kind of thing to
happen in one place in Geneva but I do
think you want that to set up that kind
of international infrastructure I think
CERN Pro is an interesting example here
because membership is not necessarily
Universal um and I think to be able to
move quickly you will want to I think
look at those Nations that are um at the
Forefront of development um that are
exposing the rest of the world to the
biggest risk um and get at least them on
board from the very beginning um as you
then expand and make sure that more
people have that have a stake get to
have a say um you also need
significantly more research and um here
the safety institutes seem really
important in my mind and I think you
also want to make sure that you build
more convergence and I think I mean lots
of people been talking here about an
ipcc for AI um not too excited because I
mean look at climate change right I mean
if if if that's our beacon on the like
we we we're doomed so we want to make I
want we need to make sure that whatever
thing we build to get more consensus
around research uh results and sort of
what the risks are and as we build that
shared understanding of risk um that
that moves a lot quicker and that we
don't as in the example of climate
change allow industry to take one or two
papers uh or in some case no paper and
invent descent and polarization around
climate science I mean we can't afford
that in AI given uh how quickly the
technology is developing um so we also
definitely need that function and then
we need an enforcement function and I
think that third function I guess is in
many ways the hardest um and again I
think we we we need to start from the
countries that expose the world to the
biggest risks rather than perhaps aim
for universality in all 193 member
states of the United Nations from the
very beginning
because yeah it seems unlikely that
you'll be able to act quick enough if
you take go down that route do you think
countries will begin launching Manhattan
projects for for AI so you could imagine
the US President coming out and saying
we're gonna we're going to build Ai and
we're going to do so safely this is what
he's saying and we're going to do this
before uh it's developed by commercial
entity this seems a pretty risky
proposition to me but I don't know would
you be excited for something like that
or what would you think I I'd like to
Rebrand it the Apollo project the Apollo
project
yes uh rather than the Manhattan
projects because that led to a bomb then
again I mean to some extent this is what
we see from open AI right or for
anthropic like they have already made
that announcement so the question is how
would if this could be substantially
safer and safety would be the the thing
driving it then I think there would
potentially be benefits I think a lot of
like the devil here would really be in
the details in how this is done and
under what conditions um and how many
precautions people are taking how
transparent it is and I I'd much rather
see um this happened at a sort of CERN
type institution or or allowing multiple
countries to work together than putting
all of my eggs in in in a basket of one
state or or sort of one president
there's this dynamic in which I mean I
think it's true to say that that the
leading AI companies right now were all
founded with safety in mind so Google
Deep Mind and open Ai and anthropic now
perhaps uh X AI that was funded by Elon
Musk these companies were founded
because the in response to others
perhaps uh acting irresponsibly and so
we are going to develop Ai and we are
going to do this uh this safety so
there's there potentially a a dynamic in
which you step into the race and then
you accelerate the race uh
unintentionally so I would worry about
that in in the situation of an Apollo
proit for AI but yeah I can see the
arguments for it too yeah I mean that
would have to if done well and you
manage to do that and you do it in
corporation with other nations you would
ideally prevent like other Rivals um in
the private sector from taking excessive
risk um and I think you would po impose
things like a hard compute limit on
those players so that you make sure that
the project you've carefully designed is
the one that that sort of we we're doing
experimenting with rather than letting
ever more entities um impose ever more
risk we're we're taking some things for
granted in this conversation we're
taking for granted that AI is advancing
pretty quickly and that artificial
general intelligence is is possible and
that that AI could be dangerous and so
on I imagine that when you in your daily
work you meet uh people who are perhaps
in politics for entirely different
reasons and quite skeptical around these
issues what do you what do you say to
them how do you pitch them so to speak
on the importance of AI safety I mean I
think there's many examples that people
can point to when they think about AI
risk and it's of and most regulatory
measures don't require you to think to
believe that artificial general
intelligence is possible or even or
imminent um as you design a response
things like um for example the issue the
regulatory measure we talked about my
favorite one regulator risk
identification is something that you
probably want for most AI applications
anyway um so often we like don't talk
about very specific sources of risk and
there's also many applications of AI
that I think everyone can understand
very quickly um and supports sort of can
lead to existential risk s for example
the video we put out over the summer
artificial escalation where um we
discuss the incorporation of AI in
decision support systems and that
potentially leading to a nuclear
exchange on the Taiwan straight is a
really good example of um an AI
application that we can build today with
the technology we have today that could
wipe us all out um I I I think there's
often a lot of common ground with the
people I talk to about um I do think
something has changed especially after
Jeffrey Hinton left Google um he met
with um the president of the European
commission Ursa Von um we've had people
like Joshua Benjo um speak out much more
clearly over the past um few months and
I think the fact that some of the most
cited AI academics um are so deeply
concerned about what it would mean if AI
would surpass or equal human abilities
um means that I think policy makers are
taking this a lot more seriously and
yeah are engaging with this topic more
deeply than they have done in the past
okay let's end by talking about autonomy
in Weapons Systems why is it that
militaries want uh autonomous weapons
what is their perceived value a speed I
think is the the biggest perceived value
speed and scale so militaries feel that
if an adversary for example would have
um a system that would move that would
be autonomous then they also need a
system that's autonomous so that they
can strike back at the same rate
otherwise a human could slow it down and
that would mean they would lose the
exchange um and soldiers are expensive
they need food they need sleep it looks
very bad to have them coming back in
caskets that too I mean it it can really
undermine public support for a war if
lots of soldiers die and come and and
and as you say come back in caskets and
or return to their family that's what's
driving a lot of interest in in the
technology how do I think autonomy
changes the balance of power between uh
powerful states and and weaker um weaker
parties in in Conflict I think what my
personal view is is that it will likely
upset this balance because what we've
seen over the past several decades is
that entities like the United States
Soviet Union um at the time China are
have a massive scale uh and can use that
scale to invest in um the the advanced
most advanced fighter pilots the the
best tanks and those are really
expensive products that like smaller
entities and smaller States can't
acquire whereas with um autonomous
weapons you could potentially have
really small drones um that are
relatively easy to manufacture or or
could even can be built Comm can be
bought commercially from Amazon and then
adapted to um have a military
application where what you need to
ensure that it sort of performs is uh
potentially also software which is
obviously easy to just copy uh and
doesn't cost you much um and if yeah if
you manage to acquire that type of
capability and it's good enough then the
relative advantage of a big Power and
their scale and and sort of capital
investment is likely going to matter
less um so it's probably going to make
smaller entities more powerful so now
now it sounds like we can perhaps save
some money and we can Pro protect
ourselves and we can save the lives of
soldiers uh why is it that fli is is
trying to uh what is it that we're
trying to prevent here maybe you can
paint us a scenario of what it would
mean to have unregulated autonomy in
Weapons Systems so I think there's three
major categories of risk that we're
worried about or sort of concerns that
we have around autonomy and weapon
systems one is the obvious one which is
the ethical one like do we really as as
a species want to yield decisions of
life and death to a machine um and is
there something human about ra waiting
war that we want to preserve uh Paul sh
who's an expert who speaks a lot about
this issue describes a situation where
he was a soldier and he was on a hill in
Afghanistan and a young girl about six
seven years old was sent by the Taliban
to scout out what was happening around
the hill and under the international
rules of War she would is at that point
a combatant there's no age limit in the
rules of War so she should have been
shot and I think if if he had been an
autonomous system he would have shot the
six-year-old girl but he felt like
morally he couldn't shoot her even
though she was giving intelligence about
his position to the Taliban I think
that's a good example of where saying
okay we can program the rules of War
into a system might have limitations
that we do want to think about very very
carefully then there is the concerns we
have around accountability like at the
moment if someone commits a war crime
you can point to that person or you can
point to that leader and you say well
this person entities's committed a war
crime but if you're a Ukrainian Soldier
or Russian soldier at the moment and in
that war you would activate a system uh
that consists of a swarm of let's say
10,000 drones and that those 10,000
systems commit war crimes at scale um
and all the only thing you did was press
the button and you were under certain
assumptions about what it would do can
you really be held accountable for every
single move for for this soldier that a
system killed who was already raising
his hands and by doing so became a
non-combatant yeah given that you're
Outsourcing we are talking about
autonomy so you are Outsourcing decision
making to these systems and so perhaps
yeah there's some there's uncertainty
around whether you can be held liable
for for the initial decision to to
activate the system ex exactly
especially if you're activating an
autonomous submarine and the one you
activated it several months ago and it's
still out there I mean to what extent
can we really point you and sort of hold
you accountable and then I think there's
a third category which I'm most
concerned about CR which is around
International Security and this is what
most sort of keeps me up at night when
thinking about Ai and Military
integration is is Taiwan straight in the
future where I think there is a severe
risk that both the US and China might
deploy autonomous systems and uh do so
at scale train those systems on
classified data um and and those systems
may be interpreting a ray of sunlight or
the movement of another system as an
attack when it's not an attack and that
leading unintended escalation and a war
that's fought at machine speed in
several seconds where um you then almost
have to retaliate because you've lost so
much equipment or you've lost so many
men and I think that's a terrifying
Prospect also because we know from
civilian AI that it often malfunctions
and it's okay because you can see it and
you can fix it but like if you in
military situations you probably have
one shot and you can't really test it
very well under battle hardened
conditions so you're going to have have
things that happen unintentionally so
that's one category of sort of security
risks on this the sort of other
categories around nonstate armed groups
terrorist groups um we're now talking a
lot about sort of the role of Hamas the
role of Hezbollah and having those types
of groups for example giving them the
ability to Target a specific ethnic
group let's say all Jewish males between
18 and 22 um that like is something I
think you
really want to avoid in in because of in
like concerns around International
Security stability um and frankly the
ability to commit Mass atrocities um so
it's that's sort of why fli is really
concerned maybe to add to that I think
what we see a lot in the debate around
autonomy and weapon system is a sort of
self- ownership fallacy where people
believe that they are going to be the
only ones that have this or they will
have the best one it is a very
persuasive argument when a soldier says
I've lost a fellow soldier in battle I
want to develop autonomy and weapon
system autonomous weapons so that I can
save future lives and no Soldier to go
through my experience again uh and
that's all fine especially if your
experience was from because you were
American Soldier fighting in Iraq and
you were fa faced with let's say Isis
that that didn't have maybe the
sophisticated capabilities that um you
are developing but if if you are faced
with an opponent of that has similar
technological capabilities as your own
then I think you reach a whole different
situation and you you you you reach the
those sort of risks of unintended
escalation that can quickly lead to a
global war and I think that's that's
often not considered in these policy
debates we we should also stress the
unreliability of these systems so we
could talk about them perhaps
analogously to to a self-driving car
that will fail I mean human drivers and
and human soldiers are also unreliable
but at least we're reli we're unreliable
in ways that are um recognizable to
other humans whereas these systems fail
in in in quite unexpected ways when I
interviewed the the autonomy expert
Frank SAU he he gave me some examples of
adversarial inputs for drone systems
where you can paint a certain
pattern on the side of a of a car and it
will be registered as something entirely
different and you can imagine
what uh Bad actors might might do with
the with you know painting this on
perhaps your own uh infrastructure such
that your weapons attack yourself and uh
all kinds of bad things could happen
there there are these problems with
autonomy and weapon
systems how is it difficult or why is it
difficult to regulate these systems
intern nationally it's difficult because
there is military advantages or military
C advantages so I think that that's what
makes it harder I'm not sure if it's
particularly difficult I mean I think
there is a growing uh group of Nations
that do feel that this needs to be uh
regulated in an new international treaty
and you see uh the UN Secretary General
the president of the Red Cross for
example to coming together several weeks
ago to issue a call uh which is really
quite unique saying okay we need to have
an international treaty and we need to
have it negotiated by
2026 um and a resolution that tasked the
Secretary General with identifying all
the options that there currently are for
regulation passed with I think six no
votes and um over 160 yes votes um so I
think that there there is quite a wide
range like Global consensus around the
need to put in limits I think there's
this disagreement about where these
limits need to be and I think um there's
also different proposals like do we
mandate a principle like meaningful
human control for example um that you
need to always have meaningful human
control over your weapon system as a
commander uh in the same way as you need
to abide by principles such as
proportionality or distinction when you
plan an attack on an international law
um or do we look at for example a class
of anti-personnel drones uh or systems
um because systems that Target military
ships or um naval ships or uh tanks
might be less problematic so like I
think there's different Avenues to go
down there are systems that attack
military objects for example tanks or
planes or structures and then there are
systems that attack people um I think
there is a difference here in that if if
your target profile is by definition
military Target profile chances that
you're going to violate International
humanitarian law are significantly
diminished and the ability to commit a
genocide using systems that Target
structures or military objects is very
different than if you are targeting
individual People based on features or
facial characteristics and that would
really be the nightmare scenario having
a a swarm of drones flying around
targeting specific people based on their
kind of inherent characteristics say we
get an international treaty but China
doesn't sign it or maybe the US doesn't
sign it does it matter it does and I
think this is I think a critical at
least in my mind a critical element that
people often miss is that at the moment
there is no regulation around autonomous
weapons whatsoever um and you see States
for example turkey will export
autonomous weapons to many nations um
unrestricted and it is also perfectly
like okay to do so whereas I think that
the risk that that poses to stability in
North Africa um to other nations is
significant and I think those other
nations have a like justifiable say in
what happens when those kind of systems
uh proliferate and I think that's why
you need a norm um and that Norm will
matter to lots of quarters of the world
that are in the United States Russia or
China so that's I think one reason why
it's important another is
if you have a sufficient super majority
that signs a treaty it becomes a norm
and you see that with a landmine treaty
uh the United States has never ratified
the landmine treaty but it does abide by
it it doesn't use landmines anywhere
outside of the Korean Peninsula um and
it made that announcement publicly
because it was faced with a new
international norm and um that pressure
went along with it even if a treaty is
not signed by by those three players it
still has value I think it will also
enable trilateral or bilateral
agreements between those players so you
can imagine having a treaty in place and
then China and the US meeting
potentially behind closed doors and
making certain agreements about what you
can and cannot do in the Taiwan Strait
that borrow from concepts of that treaty
or that say like well because this is a
norm we're going to try and have an
informal agreement that we both respect
without sort of going through uh a big
International fora uh where we can't be
seeing to do this or where yeah this
would receive significant push back so I
think yeah there's there's significant
value in having it even if um those
countries don't sign mark thank you for
coming on the podcast uh I've learned a
lot it's been a pleasure